the opening trap of south 4 takes place
in a mausoleum and some of the two
markers are named after the crew members
who helped make the movie like the art
departments painter in Napoleon Forbes
the carpenters Huber peddle and Bryan
Lumley and a miscellaneous crew member
named Chris Becker and makes sense to
see carpenters and painters immortalized
themselves on the physical set while
someone like the graphic designer Sean
Scofield got his own name in there on
this fingerprint analysis report the
head of the forensics department is
listed as David Armstrong who happens to
be sophomores director of photography
which is also considered to be the head
of the camera department and electric
department on a movie there's also some
information on this report that answers
a previously unsolved mystery about saw
tune so stick around if you want to hear
about it welcome to things you missed
soft war represents a transition for the
Saw franchise after the departure of the
original writer this would be the last
saw movie that director Darren lianbao
ceman would direct for the next 13 years
but the producers obviously wanted to
keep the series going and as a result
saw started to become more episodic the
movie would contain setups that might
not pay off for another two or three
movies and some of them are pretty well
kept secret I'm gonna uncover and talk
about even more things you missed so
let's put those words on your screen
right now
the film opens with John Kramer's
autopsy if only this guy knew how
valuable that mask will become in 2020
and the scene sets up for the big twist
of this movie the fact that the autopsy
is actually the last scene
chronologically and software takes place
at the same time in saw three the tape
and John stomach is played for detective
Hoffman and you can fully expect a
YouTube video for me in about 70 years
with a similar message because I despite
this twist being a surprise to most
we're constantly shown that time is an
important factor in saw form from the
ancient clock that John emphasizes to
Jill to the watch he angrily throws away
after losing their unborn son to the
countdown that looms over this movie's
main game to the theme of this game
being about time and patience to the
many lessons that John teaches his
victims also being about time give me
time to explain please but outside of
the concept of time there are also a lot
of clues that the events have saw three
had not yet taken place like the fact
that outside of that opening
flash-forward scene there's no mention
of John and Amanda's death and the most
recent headlines we see are all about
the events of saw - like this one that
says detective and serial killers still
missing a reference to Matthews and John
literally dipping out so that John can
take the detective to the nerve gas
house also the photos on the left side
are all photos of John's workshop at
Wilson steel plants if this was taking
place after John Kramer's autopsy they
would also have photos from the
operation this magazine cover has an
article about detective Matthews in
relation to jigsaw but nothing about dr.
denlon who by the way is mentioned
offhand in the movie but we don't know
that it's her at the time looks like
another doctor went missing from the
hospital maybe when I heard this line I
thought he was saying another doctor is
in another doctor in addition to dr.
denlon but it was really another doctor
in addition to dr. Gordon shortly after
Hoffman is seen holding a children's toy
when asked about it by agent Perez he
simply says short story believed
is not alive but if we look closely at
it it's actually one of the toys that
belongs to Corbett denlon the kidnapped
daughter from saw 3 and the saw 3
connections really don't let out because
saw four straight up shows us Hoffman
placing a note for Amanda in the middle
drawer of John's desk which is a
connection to this line from the
previous movie it seems that Darren Lin
Bausman
who I apparently can't talk about it all
without saying his full first middle and
last name was so confident that we
wouldn't notice these details did he
straight up with the date that this all
takes place on April 28th 2006 while we
don't see the exact date in saw 3 we
know that it can't be that long after
saw two where John Kramer was damn near
on his death bed last addition we also
know saw four takes place six months
after saw two Eric's been missing for
six months Kerry was gone for four days
so the timeline checks out it makes
sense that three and four taking place
on the same day also the date helps
timeline obsess people such as myself
confirm when saw two actually takes
place because saw four stated to be six
months after the disappearance of Eric
Matthews previously we could only
estimate that saw two took place in
October 2005 based on the decomposition
of Adam and Zepps bodies in the bathroom
they look like they've been rotting for
about a year but now we have something
more concrete and it fits right in with
this newspaper headline stating that the
police have released the identity of
jigsaw and it's published on November
30th it makes sense that they would keep
it under wraps after first discovering
that John Kramer was jigsaw but after
losing him and being unable to find him
for the next month they would release
his identity to the public also the
writer of this article is Jane Kim the
assistant of Darren Lim Bausman on this
movie there's another article written
later on by Jason lund the lead man of
the art department of course the big
clue where I think most of us started to
realize that saw four took place
alongside the third installment was at
the end when agent Strahm shows up at
the gideon meat-packing plant and finds
the photo of just family seen in the
previous film then there's more of jeff
abusing the lights for some reason
he really does not like lights does he
so there's a lot of evidence to look
back on that proved sophomores timeline
placement and while sophomore isn't
among my favorite saw movies I think
there's something that I like about
giving an iconic entry in a franchise
multiple direct sequels it reminds me of
the Legend of Zelda franchise where they
came out with this legendary game
ocarina of time and gave one sequel in
the timeline branch where link as a
child and one sequel in the timeline
branch she abandoned as an adult but the
interesting thing about sophomore is it
not only moves us forward in the
timeline but also flashes us back to
John Kramer's past where we can discover
even more things humans
when officer Rigg is watching back the
Jill tuck interrogation tapes he does so
on reference monitor be at the police
station we can also see there's another
monitor on this cart but the label says
9 inch HD monitor sometimes in the movie
industry you can get away with using
equipment that's props and this is
probably one of those cases in fact it
happens a lot and saw for like later on
at Riggs house and maybe here at the ice
block trap although it's possible that
these light panels were never supposed
to be on screen
when you make seven movies in seven
years that's the kind of mistake that
can happen when we first see the
newspaper article about John buying
gideon meat-packing plant there's
actually some nice lore as as opposed to
the first saw where the contents of the
articles were just random stories
apparently the building had sat
abandoned for a hundred years before
John purchased as part of his urban
renewal group project which could
explain why nobody ever discovered what
he was doing there and why the majority
of people don't even really know where
it was the main game that we followed
during sophomore is the trial of Daniel
rigged which contained a lot of
parallels to the original saw for
example Riggs game begins when he wakes
up in a bathtub just like Adam Stan
height when he began his jigsaw journey
there would be another add in parallel
later when Rigg comes upon a room filled
with photos of the crimes that took
place at a slimy motel whose red light
illumination is very reminiscent of the
dark room in Adams apartment which is
similarly lined with incriminating
candid photos on a sidenote jigsaws
punishment for Ivan is to strap him down
to this bed I mean does he not realize
that there are people who pay good money
for that kind of experience there are a
few more callbacks to the original like
the question mark seen throughout Riggs
adventure which referenced the question
mark painted on Donnie Reiko stomach for
the reverse bear trap I've mentioned
throughout this series that the
franchise has many instances of a
character playing dead in order to make
a surprise attack and that comes back
again in this one as detective Mathews
feigns death to get close to his
supposed captor art blank then at the
Chinese New Year celebration which is of
course the year of the pig we see the
origin of the pig mask worn by John's
followers and all for Sami he starts off
by using a more cartoony pig mask but in
the background there are more realistic
one like the ones that he would
eventually come to use and what I found
very interesting was another mask with
spiral patterns on the cheeks like that
of Billy the puppets
this must just be a coincidence though
because he already had created Billy as
a toy for his unborn child prior to
these events I must see it may be seen
this mask elsewhere before and may
was inspired by it another likely
coincidental connection found in the
Chinese New Year parade scene is these
little figurines which can be seen
beside John's deathbed in Psalm 3 but
back to Rigg he comes out of his
bathroom to find his house has been
turned into a trap and his phone has
been taken I wonder if jigsaw reused the
audio of the voicemail greeting from saw
to I should start selling these
voicemail greetings and fibre or
something he comes up to his first test
subject Brenda who was trapped in the
scalp chair he discovers the three-digit
combination to release her the numbers a
little nod to the area code in Toronto
where the movies 2 through 9 were filmed
it's kind of frustrating that jigsaw
could have been like the ultimate
crime-fighting machine but instead
became the ultimate crime committing
machine I mean he could have easily just
taken these photos to the police same
thing with the videotape of Ivan but no
he's got to go and put them in literal
torture devices to rig follows the path
that jigsaw had set out for him while
Strom also goes down the trail of
jigsaws clues but also stops to
interrogate Jill tuck at the beginning
of which he looks like he's posing for a
Caesar World Instagram photo
[Music]
she tells him more stories about John's
past including some that took place at
her drug clinic where we see younger
versions of some of the criminals from
jigsaws traps
Gus coal yard the guy who was taken out
by the Magnum I hole trap and saw two
gets into a fight in the waiting room
Addison Corday the woman who fell victim
to the Razorbacks trap tries to get John
to solicit prostitution from her as he's
waiting outside and Troy the man who met
his demise in the classroom trap and saw
three also seems to be a patient or at
least connected to a patient at the
homeward bound clinic the third phase of
Riggs trial brings him to a different
classroom where he discovers a husband
and wife were impaled with a series of
spikes I think there's a common
misconception here which people love to
clown on that the woman is being tested
because she allowed her husband to abuse
her the way that jigsaw phrases it and
the tape does kind of make it seem like
this is the case but I think people
forget that this is the same couple from
the elementary school flashback so it
was probably more about the woman
keeping quiet knowing that her husband
was abusing the students he stunts she's
allowed I'm not saying that makes it any
better or that she deserves to be
punished or anything but I'm just trying
to explain what might have been going
through jigsaws head I can't really
explain what was going through strahm's
head though during the quick flashes
while he's interrogating Jill
[Music]
yeah that's weird should we like call
someone throughout the series there have
been traps that were inspired by ancient
torture devices and you could say that
the knife chair that John puts easel
into was one of them though it's not
exactly the same as this Chinese torture
chair from the early 1900s because
jigsaws version gave the victim the
ability to decide if they wanted to hurt
themselves in order to pass there's also
a trap we see in John's workshop which
doesn't get used until a future movie
the glass coffin would be back in saw
five and icky around at Jill's neck
during the scenes that take place in
2006 would also return in a future film
there's another saw horror history
episode coming this Wednesday and then
it looks like I'll have to put the saw
content on hold for a little bit while
we wait for spiral to get a new release
date so if you want to make sure you're
notified when I resumed with even more
things you missed and saw five six seven
jigsaw and spiral then make sure you
subscribe to see ZZZ world for new
Horrors every week ring that DEATH
BATTLE for notifications and I'll see
you in the next one
assuming we both survive